mon d'aborder les questions que je vais
vous poser je vais juste faire une
remarque à l'ifremer qui existent en
guyane et je trouve que l'ifremer ne
vulgarise pas suffisamment les travaux
au grand public ce que vous existez vous
avez vous mené d'excellents travaux mais
le grand public ne sait pas ce que ce
que vous faites quoi si on demande à un
citoyen lambda qu'est-ce que l'ifremer
je pense pas que le guyanais sera répond
il a entendu parler de l'ifremer mais je
pense que ce serait nécessaire que vous
puissiez informé en tout cas à
vulgariser les informations je peux
répondre très d'abord peut-être à la
question très direct posé sur la
communication de l'ifremer pour nous
c'est un vrai enjeu et on a changé notre
direction de la communication il ya
maintenant il ya deux ans et faire en
sorte que les travaux d'ifremer soit
connue du plus grand nombre c'est un
enjeu prioritaire de cette direction et
je pense que dans les années de faim
dans l'année qui vient de s'écouler elle
a fait beaucoup et je pense que l on
fera encore beaucoup donc je je prends
ce point qui est que je peux au moins au
sein du comité de direction du premier
rempart tél